we will be judging everything based off
their owl equivalency level
Harry Potter is everything it was my one
true love
reponders so it's more than just like a
cool thing it's just like a way of life
all right supposed to be thoughts I
think they're almost drugs please tell
me these aren't actually cockroaches
I mean I'm into it I'm gonna get the
most cockroach looking one its fudgy its
sweet there's like two different types
of chocolate or is that caramel
Wizarding world's version of a turtle
real cockroaches tasted like this I
could live off cockroaches this is not a
chocolate frog oh this is pretty thick
well who do you think would be eating
this hufflepuffs to be hon oh god here
it goes that's good and it's all much
sugar
it's like slimy but like sweet slimy
virus poon
this would be a good dessert it looks
like a muggle that tastes like magic
chocolate frogs I'm like cousin
peppermint toads every state did the
Wizarding World so far has been very
delicious oh my god it smells really
minty it's really sweet and really thick
it's gross this is weird this tastes
like toothpaste it's basically the
peppermint filling from like a
peppermint patty I love the Frog yeah is
dance first year at Hogwarts I'm eating
these all day right
two of us best blowing bubble gum cool
well stickier than a sticky gum balls do
it why it tastes like we're chewing on
gum that someone already chewed on oh
absolutely kind of like this like harder
thicker gum catcher there's not much of
a flavor so I guess that would last all
day
mmm blueberry uh great magic doesn't
lose its flavor really quickly yeah it's
gone doesn't feel the flavor just
dripping into my throat guys how that's
our first bubble whatever blows that was
awesome you can make candies tastes like
you read in the books but you can't make
them magic any chance to bring the HP
world to life is okay by me I think I've
just gotten an idea for next date night
with my wife
except I'm definitely gonna make a
chocolate frog